bonjour à tous apple fait une nouvelle
fois parler de lui non pas sur les
iphone non pas sur les ipad mais sur le
mac pro
le mac pro ça fait un petit moment qu'on
l'attend en fin du mois les
professionnels parce que c'est vraiment
un produit qui est dédié aux
professionnels
forcément c'est paca de cadeaux c'est un
produit puissant c'est un produit qui
apporte qui m'ont beaucoup de
performances
alors vous allez voir c'est un produit
qui ne saurait tarder je sais je sais
dans sa version date un petit peu on va
faire un petit peu un état des lieux
voix quand on va arriver ce nouveau mac
pro est ce qu'il va arriver cette année
plus tard on va faire un petit peu
tourner la question et on y va
maintenant
alors c'est vrai le mac pro ça fait
beaucoup de temps qu'on l'attend la
version d'avant date quand même de 2013
or elle reste toujours assez actuelle
elle reste performante mais néanmoins il
ya des pros c'est plus un usage
professionnel qui veulent renouveler
leur parc
avoir un nouveau produit encore plus
performant et ils attendent un peu parce
qu'une fois qu'on a mis les pieds dans
apple qu'on travaille avec les os
d'apple
on n'a pas forcément envie de changer
toute sa suite logicielle on n'a pas
envie de réinvestir de tout réinstaller
pour aller sur windows sauf que si apple
continue à traîner et à ne pas sentir le
produit tiré assez rapidement un moment
les professionnels vont finir par se
lasser et finir pas ce bar est d'autant
plus que microsoft fait des produits ils
sont vraiment super bien aussi à
destination des professionnels donc
quand est ce que apple va sortir son mac
pro on l'attendait en 2017 la route en
2018 n'est toujours pas là qu'est ce qui
se passe alors en fin de compte rassurez
vous il ya des journalistes qui ont été
invités par apple allait faire un petit
état des lieux de l'univers de
l'ordinateur selon apple
où est-ce qu'ils en sont qu est ce qui
devrait arriver il ya eu des démos il ya
eu pas mal de choses et nous on va
s'attarder un petit peu sur le point du
mac pro
alors ces journalistes ont rencontré
plusieurs personnes de chez apple ils
ont rencontré john ternus ce qui est le
vice président de l'ingénierie
matérielle ils ont également rencontré
tom blogueur baugur moqueur japon 5
tonnes désolé tome qui est le directeur
marketing produits mac hardware est
également jadco plan qui est le
directeur marketing des produits vidéo
apps et grandeur sow rennes
quel directeur marketing des produits
musique afs voilà ça fait beaucoup de
monde
ils ont rencontré toutes ces jolies
personnes pour faire un tour un peu et
savoir un peu ce qui va se profiler du
point de vue effectives mans des
ordinateurs de chez apple nous ont parlé
de l'évolutivité des machines entre
elles un peu de l'avenir mais on a
quelques infos qui sont arrivés
notamment sur le mac pro et s'étonne
blogueur qui a confirmé que le maquereau
à l'arrivée ouf
oui mais pas cette année en 2019 alors
désolé si vous êtes professionnel et que
vous l'attendiez avec impatience
désolé de vous décevoir il va falloir
encore un petit peu de patience alors ne
changeait pas forcément votre parc cette
année attend dès 2019
soyez patient parce que normalement
apple devrait
l'annoncé dans le meilleur des cas ou
d'abeille ou d'aveuglé d'ici au mois de
juin 2019
donc on n'y est pas encore et si
l'annoncé en juin 2019
il se pourrait qu'il arrive dans le
meilleur des cas en septembre 2019 mais
je pense plutôt décembre 2019 dont c'est
encore un an et demi attendre pour avoir
ce joli joujou mais bon le jeu en vaut
la chandelle parce que comme je vous le
disais une fois qu'on équipe et apple
qu'on est équipé de mac on a l'habitude
on a tous ces logiciels d'autant plus le
professionnel sont des achats la licence
qui coûte quand même relativement cher
c'est compliqué d'aller acheter d'autres
licences chez les éditeurs parce que ça
vaut quand même très très cher alors
bien évidemment ils sont des produits
qui sont renouvelés ou acheter les
nouvelles licences ça peut se faire mais
dès lors qu'on est habitué à un
environnement qu'on a tous qui a utilisé
pour des produits apple
ça fait râler quand même de changer
directement d'os et de devoir changer de
fournisseur donc un peu de patience
il devrait arriver en 2019 et ça je sais
que c'est un peu long alors au final
pourquoi est-ce que la peule à
communiquer là dessus parce que l'idée
si vous voulez d'offrir des journalistes
c'est pas uniquement de dire regardez
ont fait des super truc c'est génial ça
tout le monde le sait qu'ils m'en faire
patienter un peu les professionnels
notamment par rapport aux mac pro mais
l'idée c'est vraiment ça c'est de se
dire attendez ne partez pas tout de
suite on peut faire des annonces
officielles parce qu'il est quand même
beaucoup trop tôt on laisse suite à une
petite info pour vous balancer l'info
l'histoire ne s'est pas senti tout le
monde est qu'effectivement il ne perd
pas trop de parts de marché là dessus
parce que je pense qu'apple s'est très
clairement il ya une attente derrière
qui n'attendent qu'un peu présente comme
je le disais les macpro date quand même
de 2013
donc c'est quand même très long on va
imaginer qu'en sortant en 2019 le
produit aura quand même six ans ça veut
dire que renouveler un ordinateur quand
même pour les pros tous les six ans on
peut se dire qu'un mois sont un petit
peu l'amour alors bien évidemment avec
le même projet inclut qui était déjà
très puissant très performant mais
malgré tout
besoins d'investissements ça fait râler
d'attendre ou alors d'aller acheter des
produits qu'il a quand même de 2013
alors dites moi vous si vous êtes
professionnel est ce que vous êtes prêts
à attendre un an et demi avant de
renouveler votre part qu'est ce que
c'est fait pas qu'y plus trop râler
c'est vrai le reconnaître apple est
quand même très bon dans son domaine
sont des produits qui sont super bien on
va pas se mentir un son ordinateur moi
j'ai un macbook pro alors on n'est pas
sûr du mac pro
les ja macbook pro ça fonctionne plutôt
bien c'est les bécanes qui vient dans le
temps parce que on est quand même sur
les renouvellements en minimum 5 ans
sinon dix ans donc on imagine très bien
qu'un produit qui était achetée en 2013
peut-être même après 2014 2015
on va pas se dire qu'on va changer tout
de suite après ça dépend bien évidemment
des besoins en puissance en puissance
pure est ce que ça fait pas un peu long
tous les six ans pour renouveler un
produit de tagab là parce qu'une
question que je vous pose parce que moi
je ne sais pas moi je sais que j'ai
besoin de changer mon macbook pro je
viens rend encore attendre un petit peu
puis économiser parce que malgré tout
c'est quand même très cher rôle un petit
peu pour plus d'infos sur le mac pro
j'espère que ça vous aura intéressé je
vous invite comme d'habitude elle essaie
toutes vos questions suggestions en
commentaire directement de sous quand
d'habitude je vous invite à décéder
jolie pousse à vous abonner parce qu'on
va parler énormément d'actu tech il ya
plein de choses à venir vous allez voir
c'est très intéressant merci à vous
d'avoir regardé cette vidéo portez vous
bien soyez sages vous embrasse et à
bientôt
[Musique]